she's remarkable isn't she she can't be
a little flat lash science okay for the
record that is Meryl Streep trying to
sing badly she stars in Florence Foster
Jenkins which is based on this crazy
true story of a New York heiress who was
so wealthy no one would tell her she had
a lousy voice and Meryl told are carly's
steel that being bad really is more fun
than being good well Meryl I just have
one thing to say I think you're the
future yeah it was cat in screaming no
how you're a great singer so how much
fun did you have singing badly because
it looked like it was a blast it was so
much fun well we all know Meryl really
can sing she's hit the high notes in at
least ten of her movies well as Florence
Foster Jenkins Merrill's biggest fan is
her husband played by Hugh Grant Big
Bang Theory Simon Helberg is rupiahs I
could not believe this story was real it
was a complicated story and it's a
complicated love story speaking of
musical news we're very excited to hear
you're in talks to join Emily Blunt I'm
Mary Poppins yes are you guys looking
forward to working together oh I adore
Emily and I think she's gonna be amazing
in this known for her championing of
fierce females Meryl spoke on behalf of
Hillary Clinton at last week's
Democratic National Convention but it's
her epic battle cry that got all the
attention that scream you light up when
you do it that was a little bit of a
Florence Foster Jenkins moment that's
actually my more like cheerleading at
Bernhard's High School have you seen it
back what was that moment like cuz that
just looks incredible
refining you picked the perfect dress I
had a really nice Gucci outfit to wear
I took it in front of the committee
which my daughters who were attending
and they decided they said the good she
looks better but she's they all said yes
wear the dress yes to the dress